calificó la caída de kabul en manos de
los talibán de desgarradora pero joe
biden se mantiene firme en su decisión
de retirar las tropas estadounidenses de
afganistán y culpa a los líderes afganos
después de que el presidente hasra fanny
lu hiera del país
los líderes políticos afganos se
rindieron y huyeron del país militares
afganos se derrumbaron a veces sin
intentar luchar en todo caso los
acontecimientos de la semana pasada
reforzaron que cualquier implicación
militar
ahora era la decisión correcta
tras las escenas de afganos desesperados
abarrotados en el aeropuerto de la
capital en busca de un medio para huir
hayden se comprometió a ayudar a los que
habían trabajado con los estadounidenses
durante el conflicto de dos décadas y
que ahora podrían enfrentarse a las
represalias del grupo insurgente
entretanto en territorios aún y en se
los republicanos también critican la
retirada la califica de precipitada y
mal preparada a pesar de que donald
trump fijó una fecha de salida aún más
temprana para las tropas de
estadounidenses si insiste en salir al
menos podría haberlo planeado
un desastre total lo presenciamos en la
pantalla gente aferrada a costado del
avión desesperada tratando de salir de
allí porque saben que van a ser
asesinados por los talibanes porque
estaban colaborando con nosotros tras el
caos de los últimos días badén se ha
visto obligado a enviar tropas de
regreso al país para asegurar el
aeropuerto y más evacuaciones llevando
en total en terreno alrededor de 7.000
soldados maiden advirtió que si los
ciudadanos estadounidenses son atacados
por el talibán eeuu responderá con una
fuerza devastadora mientras tanto los
afganos se enfrentan a un futuro
aterrador una vez más a merced del grupo
militante